what did you do to piss off this
documentarian and I think he was just
going for what he thought would cause
the most flagrant insanity of murder
mayhem and madness right that's what he
was going for that's the stuff that he
was trying to tag and he did a good job
of just making it crazy dude he well he
there was something specific and it
actually bothered maybe and maybe I
noticed it more just because I'm in
industry and I know how annoying editing
is right but like the the the
documentary obviously attire King
everybody knows it the episodes were
about like 40 some-odd minutes right so
they made it for TV they thought that
they were gonna sell it to a TV channel
cuz they had commercial breaks built-in
right yeah and he would leave it in a
little bit longer when he was filming
you he would leave him before you were
gonna start recording because you were
offering to like help spruce up the
scene going hey why don't I introduce
you guys I'll come in from the apartment
or I'll get out he'd never done he is
not a director he's a turtle connoisseur
the guy's deeply into collecting turtles
and he ran some nightclubs but he's not
a director and he'd be there just Langer
and I'd be like okay I'm gonna come
through the door we're gonna do it like
this I did that stuff with him 10 times
if you listen at that exact moment the
camera man's like doctor eggs so much
better than Eric no listen to the audio
he says it right there you can hear it
hilarious the cameraman was sick to
death of him he was a freakin amateur
about the entire process but it saved
him in a lot of ways because I just
thought he didn't know what he was doing
but he had such an alternative plan this
dude came to me and just said hey I'm
making a show about wildlife education
conservation I got Richard Branson
talking about all the lemurs on his
island and I'm a turtle dude I'm the
number one collector of turtles of the
road the dude's got millions in Turtles
uh-huh I've got all these Turtles and
I'm going to talk about the world of
conservation for wildlife and I know
you've done all this great stuff with
your Tigers and all of your work in
Sumatra is your ranger stations that
you've built there I want to just
document all of that and I know you've
got stuff going on Africa I'm going to
come with you to Africa on your next
trip this is it man
salt and then and that's for two and a
half years but he's hitting me with that
five different times of long days of
filming interviews in a chair for hours
and I didn't get it exactly what was
going on so he never told you he was
making Tiger King the entire time oh
absolutely not man this is conservation
education about captive wildlife helping
to save a wild life in the wild which is
my gig it's much one of my hearts about
and so he was able to step all over me
because I was holding on a dream job and
he said HBO had it a lot and it was
going what a [ __ ] scumbag so you do
him the favor
you help him out with the lie that he
told you about and then he tries to make
you look like a douche bag
when you're clearly the cleanest one of
the three people in this documentary I
hope not by leaps and bounds right I
mean the other do care you were the
apple store you were the apple store Joe
was like an Android and then Carroll was
like a beeper or something I don't know
what the [ __ ] was going on at deli out
of this world yeah I mean if I was you I
would be like I don't want to be
included with them at all only drama is
gonna come from the two of them I told
that exact story on camera huh a dozen
times because they asked me 900
questions during the 900 questions over
hours and hours they'd slip in a
question about the industry zoos and
then what about Carol
what about Joe what about and I give
them you know I just say this is this
and that but I'm not into that guys I'm
not looking to do a show about those
guys I don't want to be in the drama
they got trouble there's nothing but
trouble gonna come out of it
Oh ain't no problem and then on the side
Rebecca talkin who's his co-director the
other person but the other producer of
the show right beside Fagin the staff
tagging all the girls that work here on
the side and stuff and going who do you
sleep with who's your boyfriend
what you over here what's it like here
what really goes on what's the drama and
then they started telling me that and I
said that's not cool man
leave the staff alone it's not gonna
happen I said if she keeps this up it
won't happen they leave they come back a
second time she blabs again and I said
she's off the set property ever again I
don't hear from her see you later and
they kicked her out
and they came three more times without
her because she was so odd I'm like why
is she so obsessed ah little did I know
because we were making murder mayhem the
madness not conservation of tigers in
the wilds of Sumatra yeah it was they
had to they had to make you more
salacious than you were oh yeah I mean
they had seen a crazy bat lady that just
murdered her husband huh probably at
least that's what the world thinks
right her seems like she killed her
husband Carroll killed her husband
that's that that's the meme I mean she
killed her husband let's be honest she
killed it like or she knows where he is
if she didn't do it she knows what
happened he's been there a long time
[Laughter]